si vous êtes boxeur cette solution va
vraiment vous intéresser c'est une boîte
française qui s'appelle
uppercut alors je vous explique c'est
pour s'entraîner et améliorer ses
capacités de box vous avez en fait
plusieurs capteurs qui vont représenter
des points clés lorsque vous allez boxer
au niveau du menton au niveau des codes
bref le sternum je vous passe un peu ça
si vous êtes boxeur vous savez
d'ailleurs moi je suis pas boxeur et en
fait c'est une chaussette connectée que
vous allez mettre sur votre sac de
frappe qui vous permettra de travailler
sur différents éléments la vitesse la
force le volume bref vous avez vraiment
pouvoir améliorer complètement votre
technique de box et en plus de ça et ce
qui est vachement intéressant c'est que
il y a deux modes le premier mode c'est
libre vous tapez les différents endroits
et ça vous permettra de voir les
différentes zones est-ce que vous avez
fait grâce à ça il va venir analyser les
patterns de box que vous avez parce que
probablement fait toujours un peu les
mêmes coups donc il vous dira ok vous
faites ça vous ne frappez pas forcément
là et vous permettra de faire évoluer
votre box donc je trouve ça vachement
malin vachement intelligent c'est une
grande chaussette connectée que vous
allez mettre sur votre sac de boxe la
société c'est hyper cute et si elle vous
intéresse allez jeter un coup d’œil
directement sur leur site et puis
surtout vous dites-moi ce que vous êtes
boxeur oui non bien que cette solution
pourrait vous intéresser